thousands marched on the streets of
kinshasa the capital of democratic
republic of congo
protesting against what they say is
rwandan military aggression in the east
of the country
people here say rwandan president paul
kagame is behind a recent series of
attacks by the rebel group m23
we're protesting because of what paul
kagame has been doing in our country for
decades now today we are saying enough
is enough this must stop
the diplomatic relations between our
country and rwanda should stop and our
ambassador in rwanda needs to come home
tens of thousands of people have fled
their homes because of the fighting the
attackers occupied several towns and
villages congo's army took some of them
back
some people have since returned home
i fled and spent four days in a camp for
displaced people near gomer but when i
returned to my house it was already
looted rundown soldiers came with trucks
and looted several houses including mine
congo's army has struggled to contain
the attacks which started in november
rwanda's government denies
is no being
of honor soldiers in drc
and from there
there could not be any collaboration
with any other force present in eastern
dlc if there is no presence of
soldiers
both rwanda and uganda have been accused
of meddling and looting minerals in
eastern congo ever since they invaded in
the 1990s
[Music]
ten years ago un investigators said
rwanda supported and commanded m-23 when
it took control of much of the north
kivu province that time congo's army
defeated them and pushed them over the
borders with rwanda and uganda with
international military support
that's what the protesters want congo's
army to do again
the international community is calling
for peace talks but people here and many
congolese say they shouldn't have to
make a deal with what they see as
foreign invaders
malcolm webb al jazeera